non-minimalists
in the not so distant past we have many
different physical artifacts for our
media books
cds dvds now we have
eliminated that physical clutter with
digital subscriptions audible
apple music netflix apps but we've
swapped
one problem for another we now have a
plethora
of digital subscriptions to address
all of our tastes instead of the
physical artifacts
how do we now appropriately curate these
multiple
digital subscriptions and still satisfy
ourselves
since each service has programs
exclusive
to its platform what a well-written
question
it's also the longest lightning round
question ever
like that is they maximized every
character on twitter there
but it's very well written and here's
what i'll say i'll give you a pithy
answer we'll expand on it
my pithy answer is this a minimal a
minimalist life
is a well curated life let me do that
again
my pithy answer is a minimalist life
is a well curated life that's also
ultimately what we're talking about here
today we're talking about any of this
type of clutter
obviously on the private podcast this
week ryan will get more into the sort of
mental clutter the additional physical
clutter
hidden clutter etc but what we're
talking about is curating
our life think of a museum the reason
it's beautiful isn't because it has
nothing in it
it has the things that are essential the
building
itself and then the things that add
value the art which changes regularly
and so
but it doesn't have any of the excess
stuff
that is what we're talking about when
we're talking about clutter
now sebastian's question specifically
has to do with
digital clutter we've talked a bit about
that with lauren's question but this is
a different question
this is hey we've replaced cds dvds
books with my kindle or netflix or
apple music or whatever we've swapped
one problem
for another i don't know that i agree
with that necessarily that's
it's swapping a boulder for a pebble
yeah pebbles can certainly be
annoying especially they get caught in
your shoe right
but the physical stuff is a boulder
the digital stuff especially if we
curate that
as well which i think it's a fair point
like we don't want to sign up for a
bunch of different subscriptions yeah
that we never use
that's just a waste of money and if you
want to waste money that's fine
but i don't see the reasoning behind
that in fact on the private podcast this
week ron i want to talk to you about
i'm going to give you a list of all the
things i just unsubscribed to this past
weekend
and because uh you're going to be asking
me some questions about the news and
and stuff so anyway there was one last
word that stood out to me in sebastian's
question
now last sentence he said how do we
appropriately curate these
multiple digital subscriptions and still
satisfy ourselves since each service
has programs exclusive to its platform
well-written question and what i'll say
is
most of the things that we think are
satisfying
are not nourishing right yeah
and so am i being nourished by this is
it actually increasing my well-being or
is it
only bringing me pleasure yeah no
i i totally agree um a piece of me wants
to say
if you're looking towards these things
for satisfaction uh you will never be
satisfied so i mean
just reiterating how yeah nourishment
and satisfaction are not the same
um my pith answer is this sebastian
stop searching for answers and start
taking action
and uh i mean you could even make that
pithier and just say that truth leads to
action but here's the thing is
sebastian is searching for an answer how
how do i do this
what's the appropriate amount there's
obviously
some discontent that's happening right
now
and uh sebastian you don't need
a how-to in order to start taking action
uh
so i think that applies to a lot of
things where sometimes we
we search for answers and we use that as
an excuse to not
take action and if you understand the
why deep enough
then the how to tends to take care of
itself and the reason that happens is
you're going to know like oh crap i look
at my bank statement
and i have 13 different subscriptions to
the new york times and to hulu
and to showtime and and and all of these
different
platforms some of them might be adding
value to your life
you're going to know that if you
can be candid with yourself you're going
to have that gut feeling
and so that's why there isn't as ryan
says a how-to of well yes here are the
seven
services you everyone should have and
then that's it you're a minimalist
because that could be extreme overkill
for someone yeah
and for someone else that might not be
enough and so
identifying what is enough will help you
identify what is clutter
oh tweet that podcast sean boom
you